oder nicht ganz unrecht sagt Professor
Krause wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden
habe bisher mit ihrer Ängstlichkeit wir
sind über ängstlich das ist richtig
damit spielt er ja auch aber er will das
hat ja die altkanzlerin gesagt er will
die EU zerstören oder will die Nato
zerstören er will in Europa eine
russische Dominanz herstellen und das
ist das entscheide das sollten wir uns
nicht gefallen lassen das wollte Stalin
1945 da lag Europa aber völlig in
Schulen Asche heute müssen wir uns das
nicht gefallen lassen aber wir lassen
uns das gefallen weil wir eben noch so
viele so viele europäische Staaten sind
gut das bleibt auch so aber der besten
hat inzwischen eine Geschlossenheit die
finde ich ganz gut wir die Nase hat
gesagt die repräsentieren eine Milliarde
Menschen finde ich auch gut also und wir
sind in einem zweiten Kalten Krieg das
müssen wir uns jetzt mal wirklich vor
Augen halten und wir wissen nicht mal
sicher ob dieser Kalte Krieg kalt
bleiben wird weil Protein hat eine
sozusagen die Art und Weise Dinge
durchsetzen zu wollen die er sich in den
Kopf gehen
leichter mit dem Kalten Krieg weil wir
so diese beiden Blöcke zumindest noch
nicht haben es gibt viele die sind
Unentschieden oder besinnen sich erstmal
auf sich selbst verdienen hat glaube ich
damit gerechnet dass er sehr schnell
viele Verbündete hat und auch damit hat
er sich verkalkuliert nein wer das geht
ja nicht um Blöcke der Kalte Krieg war
ja nicht an an Spiel von zwei Blöcken
gegenüber es war ein ein die
Herausforderung der Sowjetunion sie
wollte Europa am besten ganz Europa
beherrschen sie hat nur bei Osteuropa
geschafft hat sich der Haus später im
Block geschnitzt aber die
Blockkonfrontation war nicht das
Wesentliche des ostwest-konfliktes so
schließen wir diese Sendung ich danke
Ihnen der Krause danke Ihnen Frau
Zimmermann Herr Müller und ganz kurzer
Fassbender in die Runde hat sich
irgendjemand aus Sorge vor diesem Herbst
vor diesem Winter ein Notstromaggregat
schon zugelegt wird es sein Klopapier
das ist der optimistische Blick in die
nächsten Wochen und Monaten wird dann
gegen fürs zuschauen hier bei Bild bis
nächsten Sonntag
[Musik]